hello and welcome to today's webinar
my name is jonathan trowe and i'm a
curator here at sra
and today i'll be demonstrating how to
access our new data format
sra aligned reads and some of the
features and benefits that that offers
as well as how to use amazon's athena
resource to search sra metadata in the
cloud and
help narrow down your search to runs
that contain data of interest before you
really ever need to download or dump
anything
so just a quick overview we'll start out
with a little bit of background sort of
s3 in the cloud why then we'll move on
to amazon web services
the registry of open data i'll explain
what
sra aligned read format is and we'll
i'll show how to get started on athena
and
then we'll move into some example
workflows in athena
and finally i'll show how to access the
aligned read format on the command line
and then we'll move on to question and
answers
so sra in the cloud why have it you know
you can do some of this searching and
access from ncbi directly why have it in
the cloud well sra data archive format
is now over 18 petabytes which is great
it's a lot of data and there's a lot of
interesting stuff there
but it's a lot of data that can be
really hard to search which is not so
great because when there's that much
data you need some way to narrow it down
to what you actually care about
and so in this regard athena offers a
number of advantages
it provides new and robust search
capabilities to sra
cloud customers on aws we also have
some search features available on
bigquery for gcp users
but what athena really allows us to do
is facilitate
fast search using parallel parallel
execution of queries
with multiple methods of access so what
i'll be showing today is mostly the
browser-based query builder which i
think is what most new users will want
to start with
but they also have a collection of
client libraries that can be used within
your workflow or you can just access
it using the command line interface so
you get fast search with a lot of ways
to access it depending on what your
personal workflow is and it this is a
benefit to ncbi is that it's a great
foundation for us to continue updating
this
and changing things and to be able to
quickly respond to user feedback so i'll
have
an address you can write into with
suggestions at the end of the
presentation
and we really need that feedback from
people who are using it to guide future
development to figure out what we want
to do next and what would be the best
service to our users
and finally it can be pretty easy to get
started with sql there's a little bit of
a learning curve if you've never used it
before
but it gives you a lot of power with
drilling down into the data to find
exactly what it is you want
and to that we'll go to our first poll
and we just want to gauge
for attendees who are online now how
familiar are you with
sql it's ranging from i've never heard
of it
to your pro and use it all the time this
will sort of help us get a gauge on that
so we've got a split there i'm not going
to do an in-depth
sql tutorial today i'll cover just a
little bit of basic terminology for
beginners
but we do have a few links here if you
want to explore that more and you're new
to it so i've got a couple links to
athena's
let me go ahead let me go ahead and stop
sharing the poll
okay now you're back in okay so we've
got a few links here
to amazon's own documentation
and they've got a basic rundown of the
implementation there in athena
in addition to this there are numerous
online tutorials
both free and paid which can give you a
basic introduction to working with sql
amazon's registry of open data is a
listing of publicly available data sets
and it's a way to kind of search and
find data that's been made available for
general use
and sra has had a set of coded focused
data up there
since july and the new aligned read
data format that i'm going to talk about
today is also available there now
this brings a number of benefits so it
allows you to access a large volume of
cobia 19 related raw read data
at full cloud speeds and at no cost to
you
in addition it lets you analyze this
data in addition to
your own cloud-hosted data sets you can
easily combine these
and if you want to set up a pipeline
there in the cloud to combine both data
sets that's pretty easy to do
and have all of your data files in a
single location which i think can be
a really easier way to deal with some of
this data
i mentioned that our new data format are
the
sra aligned reads what are those
so it's compressed data format it is in
some ways
similar to existing sra data and that it
can
be used with the sra toolkit to dump
data formats but it also has some new
data in it as well that's not available
anywhere else
so briefly contigs were created from
runs in sra that were found to contain
coronavirus k-mers by our taxonomy
analysis tool
and that uses a k-mer approach to
identify the origin of reads in a run
and any run that had at least 100 hits
to coronavide or
child taxa was then selected for
analysis
and a few other selection criteria were
applied to those like minimum read
length and sequencing platform
and contigs were created from that
resulting set of runs
via guided assembly to the soros kobe 2
refseq genomic sequence
and if contigs were successfully created
then those reads were mapped back to the
contigs
and coverage was calculated and so these
sre aligned read objects they contained
the contigs that were constructed
they also contain the raw reads that
were used to construct those contents
and you can dump that data
kind of however you want with the
toolkit so you have access to the
individual raw reads or the context
individually
so if you have the sra aligned read
object
you can use fastq dump from the toolkit
to dump fast q just as you would with
any normal sra run
but if what you really care about are
those fasta contigs you can just dump
those and get those in fast format as
well
and one thing i'll note is that a number
of these biosamples are not present in
genbank
so these represent a brand new sequence
that's really only available here
and if what you care about are both the
contigs and the reads you can see
the reads mapped onto the contigs by
using the toolkit to dump in sam format
you can see where those align to the
individual contacts in addition
these aligned reads are smaller size
than our standard s-ray format
one reason for that is that they don't
have quality scores so this makes them
quite a bit smaller
to download a lot smaller to work with
so dumps on these
objects are much faster and so it's just
about getting you
into the data and working with it as
quickly as possible
now here's going to be our second poll
questioning how familiar you are with
athena
and so this is as i mentioned our first
release of
searching of metadata and athena so i'll
be curious to see
how many of our users are familiar with
it and have used it before
and so we the aligned read objects
as i'm about to show we've set up
metadata and athena that lets you do
specific searches
on submitted and calculated metadata to
help you find the ones
the specific context or reads that are
of most interest to you
so it looks like the majority of people
here haven't used it before
so that's great we'll um we'll walk
through an example of how to get it set
up if it's your first time
and so it's actually pretty easy to get
started with all right
so we have these new aligned read
objects with new data
but we also have new metadata that you
can query using athena so
since a lot of people here have never
used it what is athena it's a query
service for s3 data analysis
and it allows you to directly query
data that's stored in amazon s3 using
standard sql syntax
and this means there's no need to
manually transform the data for querying
you don't have to like download some xml
file from us
and then transform it into some sudo
database and try to query it
amazon has tools that kind of does this
for you automatically and it makes it
really easy to kind of just be up and
running in a few minutes and i'll show
an example of that during setup
and the data we've uploaded there allows
you to use athena to search
taxonomy blasts and annotation results
for these aligned read contigs
so after the contacts were created for
sra aligned reads the taxonomy was
assessed
via two methods the first is that
contigs were assessed using our sars
cov2 detection tool which uses a similar
camera-based approach to our taxonomy
analysis tool and the second is that the
contigs were
checked to be a megablast against the
nucleotide blast database and all of
these results are available for querying
and athena which
just allows you to focus on the runs or
reads of interest you before ever
downloading the data
and you can query these calculated
metadata results in combination with the
submit user submitted metadata such as
sample information
to get an even more focused result
so there are two separate buckets of
data that are available for querying and
athena that i'm going to talk about here
today and i've got them in two columns
here to kind of try to make it clear
that there's two separate sets and they
can be queried together and you can even
import them to the same database in
athena but i'm going to talk about them
separately just
for conceptual reasons the first is this
aligned read metadata this is
calculated metadata on these contigs and
so here we've got
individual individual data on the
contigs like coverage and taxonomy id
and their contact length
there's also taxonomic content analysis
of the context so you can search for
records based on camera hits to your
taxonomy level of interest for instance
there's also blast results here so you
can search for records based on
it to your excession of interest or the
hit length of the percent identity or
the bit score for instance
and the s3 bucket address for that set
of metadata is here you don't need to
memorize that or anything it's also
present in our documentation it's just
sort of there for the record
in addition to this we have available
total sra metadata
and this includes user submitted sample
information for everything in sra so
where the geographic location where the
sample was collected or the collection
technique
this includes sequencing and library
information is it single-ended paired in
what was the sequencing platform
as well as taxonomic content analysis
for everything in sra
so again you can search based on camera
hits your species of interest
or if you want to look at a metagenomic
sample and get a look at what's
what's in there by our analysis before
downloading it yourself you can do that
too and just get a list of it
and this is the s3 address for that
bucket
which again is just here for the record
so these can be queried individually but
you can query them together
to get a little bit more of a focused
and tilted result and i'll show an
example of that later
since we have some people who are not
familiar with sql i'm going to do a very
brief crash course and a couple of key
terms which will hopefully help you
follow along with the basic queries
first is select this is a command to
extract data from a table you're
essentially telling
the database what you want to get back
in your answer and so a lot of times
you'll use
select star or asterisk this means it's
a wild card give me everything or you
might say select just the run accession
only one of the run accessions back
from is the class to specify which
tables to extract from so
select the running sessions from the
contig table let's say
and where is the filter for that table
so
uh select the running sessions from the
contact table where coverage is greater
than 100x
and then order by allows you to order
the result by a specified column so you
might order by
coverage descending so you get the
highest coverage first on down so
select the running sessions from the
contig table
where coverage at least is at least 100x
order by coverage
so we're gonna go into the actual athena
demo now where i'll show basic setup
and then we'll i'll show a few queries
as well and i'll begin with a basic
query that can be an easy one to start
with if you're new to sql and then i'll
move on to a couple more complex queries
that connect submitted sample metadata
with calculated
contact information so when you
start with athena you'll see this page
depending on where you've logged into
aws you might be on
various different pages but you can
usually always go to this little
services drop down
and start typing and it will auto
complete for whatever you're looking for
so here you can type athena
or if you've recently visited it'll show
up over here and you can even start and
put it in your favorites but
any of those you can click on it'll take
you to the start page
click the get started blue button and
you'll end up here
on the query editor and this is where
you would actually type in queries you
wouldn't have queries already here like
i do
and in fact you wouldn't have databases
or anything yet so what you would want
to do is go to connect data source
and this is where how we're going to
point athena at the data we actually
want to query
for a lot of these pages we're going to
leave the settings on default and i'll
tell you when that's not the case but
we're going to start here we're going to
leave it on query data and amazon s3
and aws glue data catalog and click next
and here i'm going to leave it on setup
crawler and aws glue to retrieve schema
information automatically
the crawler is going to automatically
scan the data source the s3 bucket
it's going to identify the data formats
and sort of infer the schema so it's
going to make a database for us out of
this s3 bucket
if you want to do this manually you can
you can import the tables manually and
define all the columns and
fields this is more of a power user move
we wouldn't recommend this for
anyone beginning or who doesn't have a
really specific reason because it's
certainly more effort and
the glue caller will sort of do it for
you automatically which is what we're
going to do here today
so i'm going to click the connect to aws
glue button
that opens up aws glue and a new tab
and here we need to give a name for our
column for our crawler rather and i'm
sort of call that whatever you want call
mine demo two
we're going to leave this option on data
stores and click
next and here you definitely need to
make a change so we need to give it the
path to our s3 bucket that we're hoping
to query
so i just i have that saved over here
this is just the path to the aligned
read metadata
i'm going to paste that there click next
and here i'm going to say no for add
another data store if you wanted to you
could go back and add the total sra
metadata
here as well so if you click yes it'll
take you back and let you put in another
s3 address for instance but i'm going to
leave this as is and click next
and we need to choose a role here i'm
using a personal account because i think
this is probably what most people would
be using when they were first starting
out
and if that's that's the case then you
can just sort of create a role name here
um it's it can be whatever you want if
you happen to be logging in through
an institutional account where they are
controlling all the roles and policies
you may need to choose an existing role
so you would select here and pick one
from the drop down of available options
but i'm going to go ahead and create one
ah i've
used that one before demo 4 then
demo 10 certainly i haven't done that
many
uh click next and frequency we're just
going to have it run on demand
you don't need to do this every time you
want to query athena this is an initial
setup and once we've imported it to a
database you can come back and query it
whenever you need to you would only need
to run this again if we change
something about the underlying structure
like added in a new table or something
and that would we would have
communication about that so i'm going to
click next
there and finally we need to select the
database to import this to
if you have existing ones you could
select one of those from up here
i'm just going to create a new one
call it demo 10 create and click next
and here you can look over all the
information you put in
if you want to go back and change it you
can this looks okay to me though so i'm
going to click finish
and what this does is it creates a
crawler for you which is in this list
and this is your first time you just
have one there
so the one i just created you can see
it's never run before
but if you look at the other crawlers
i've run in the past you can see these
usually take about one to two minutes to
run so not too
not too long and it the scanning of this
data is is inexpensive it should
generally cost less than a dollar
and then to run it after you've selected
it here you click run crawler and it'll
start running
in the interest of time i'm not going to
wait a couple of minutes for this to
finish i'm going to go ahead and go back
to
my athena window and
where i've already imported some
databases but you can see that demo
10 the database i just created exists
here it doesn't have tables yet because
that's still
populating but in a minute or two it'll
have those tables
but i'll start with an aligned reads
table that i've imported previously a
couple of quick things i want to show if
you want to see which tables are
available in this database you can click
this little down arrow and it'll show
you over here
on the left and if you want to further
look into the contents of
like the blast in table for instance it
shows you the different columns here so
like
accession the length
score percent identity etc but it can
usually be
it's often a little bit easier if you
click on these three dots and click
preview table
it'll just show you the first 10 rows
that table so you can sort of see
everything that's that's in it so you've
got the running section this is the
name of the contig and then you've got
information about the blast hit
the bit score the length of the hit
percent identity
etc so using that preview feature can be
a good way to get a sense of what's in
there
a couple other interface things i'm
going to point out before going to the
demo queries
one is that after you run a query it
shows you here how long it took and how
much data was scanned
data how much data scanned is how you're
charged in athena and
they have the pricing on their website
it works out to five dollars per
terabyte
so all the queries i'm going to show
today costs pennies
and i'll cover that more at the end
also if you want to save these results
these results are saved to an s3 bucket
for you but if you want to
download the results in csv format you
can click this little button here and
it'll just download it for you
if you want to if you have a big result
set that you want to analyze offline and
look out further you can do that and
that
shows up there if you have a query that
you
think you want to run again in the
future you want to check back and see if
new data is coming in for this query
you can once you have it here in your
query window you can click save as
give it a name and a description i'm
going to cancel here but if when you
click save there it'll show up here
under your saved queries
and you can see i have some here if i
just click on one of these
it will bring it up in my query window
here
all right if this is your very first
time using
athena what you one more thing you may
need to do is go to this work group tab
and you'll need to have a work group
with an s3 bucket associated with it
which is where your results will be
stored
so if you already have a work group with
an s3 bucket associated you can select
it here
and click the switch work group button
and then it'll be active if not you can
click create work group
you can give it a name you can enter the
address of your s3 bucket
and click create down here and it will
show up in this in this list and you can
switch to it
so i'll show an example
of a query now so this is the first
query i'm going to go ahead and run this
this is a pretty basic one we're just
querying the contigs table
and this gives this has a list of all
the contents that have been constructed
for the
sra aligned read objects and so i'm
selecting everything from the context
table where the tax id
is for soros cov2 and the coverage is
greater than 100x
and the length is greater than 20 000
and you can see my results down here
so this just gives you a list of all the
contents that might be of interest to
you
in this case and if if you're a beginner
to sql this might be a simple one that
you could
use you can toy with some of these
options here instead of coverage maybe
you would want to look at hits or
something else just to get a sense of
how you can change these queries to
get the result you're actually
interested in and you can see it shows
data scanned here was only 42 megs in
this case so i mean this query
costs less than a penny actually but you
can do some interesting stuff here and i
think if you combine submitted metadata
with our calculated metadata you get
more interesting results and so this is
an example of that
here i am querying both the total sra
submitted metadata and the
blast results for the aligned reads so
i'm starting with
a sub query where i'm selecting all of
the running sessions from the blast
results
where they got a blast result that had a
tax id of soros cov2 and then for all
those accessions
i'm going to the submitted metadata for
those runs
and i'm getting the cut the name of the
country where the sample was collected
and also taking account of that country
each time each time a country comes up
and i'm ordering by that count and so
what we see down here in our results
are you can see where for all these
contigs where were those samples
actually collected
so you can see we have 1700 from usa
1600 from australia and on down and so
if for instance you're interested
in one specific region like perhaps
south africa you could drill down into
that
more more carefully and look at the
actual data underlying that
so here's another one more example if
for instance you're
interested in the south african data i'm
here taking the
querying the total sra metadata table
and looking for samples that were
collected in south africa and then i'm
using all of the runs
that that returns and i'm looking for
the corresponding hits in the
aligned reads blast table that so any of
those runs collected in south africa
which ones had blasted the source code
v2 and i'm
looking at those and the maximum bid
score and so you get
the maximum bid score over here and you
have the
contigs listed over here and we can see
that there's
a number of good hits from this one in
particular so if you wanted to go
and search and get the data for this run
you can do that pretty easily
so i'm here bringing up a command line
tool uh really i'm just logged into a
little ec2 instance here
this is uh really easy to get started
with
if you have no experience with this on
our on our cloud youtube channel we have
a little video that shows you how to
start an ec2 instance and get the
toolkit installed there and it's like a
little six minute video it's very easy
and this is a free tier instance so it
doesn't cost a lot to get started on
this
but once you have a run of interest that
you want to
look at the aligned reads for in the
contigs
you plug the run accession into this
s3 address which uh no need to memorize
this is also in our documentation which
i'll have a link to at the end
and here i'm using the amazon command
line interface to
copy this to my instance here
so when i do that see it copies very
quickly
and i now have this sra aligned reads
files here
and once you have that you can interact
with it using the toolkit as you would a
normal run so if you wanted to dump
fastq
you can do that here i'm just going to
dump the first five reads
standard out so that it will
be more easily seen so you can dump
fastq if you want
get the raw reads out and do your own
alignment or analysis there as you can
see
it has placeholder holder quality scores
because
the qualities have been removed from
these redline objects but
if what you really care about are the
fasta contigs
which i said previously some of which
are represent a new sequence these
aren't samples that are in
genbank you can get just that out and so
you can use the dump ref fasta tool to
dump just the contigs from these objects
and i'll dump this to
just a file here to dump this quite fast
and if you look at the top of this file
you can see we have the contact name
here along with the
fasta sequence of the contact and if we
they're all in there so if we
just grep for all the contact names we
got the
entire set of context from this run in
one single file and if what you prefer
instead is to look at the
aligned read information
you can use sam dump to
dump that out and this dumps to stand it
out by default
so you can see in the header all of the
all the references
are the assembly references are contigs
and here you've got
the reads aligned with this those
contexts you can if you want to
visualize where those reads align to the
context you can do that as well
um and if you want and if you want the
reads in fasta you can do that too so
you can interact with these with the
toolkit just like you would
any other object in sra but you get
these extra
contigs which aren't really represented
anywhere else which i think will be of
interest to a lot of people
they're designed to be small and fast to
work with give you access to the
underlying reads and the assembled
contigs
and whatever format makes the most sense
for your pipeline
and the athena add-on allows you to
narrow your search to specific data of
interest
before you ever need to download or dump
the data so you don't need to
download dump align the data yourself
and then
see if there happens to be anything of
interest there you can that's already
been done so
you can use the blast results or the
content results to confirm that the data
is of interest to you immediately that
it has taxonomy hits that you're
interested in
and then just pull those runs that you
know have useful information
and start analyzing from there
so the queries are also included here in
the presentation and that's available
for download
a quick note on cost this is the
predicted cost of today's examples in
athena
so the original the first query i did
which was contigs by length
cost less than a penny the other two the
geographic location count and the top
blast hits were both a little under 10
cents
these are the costs based on current
amazon pricing that could change at some
point in the future but as you can see
it's
pretty easy and cheap to get started
just get your feet wet here so
this is something you're interested in
i'd certainly encourage you to do that
uh which leads me to feedback is welcome
we really rely on
our users to help us improve these
resources so please check out us right
in the cloud check out athena
it's pretty easy to get started with let
us know what you think if there if there
are problems you have or things
we can make better let us know that let
us know what other features you'd like
in the future we we plan to
continue development of this and we
really rely on user feedback to know
what would be most useful to the
scientific community and what would help
you
and if you have suggestions you can use
this suggest that ncbi address to send
that information to us
and then finally a couple quick urls at
the end
the first url is to our sra cloud
documentation this has the s3 addresses
for all of the athena data all the s3
data you can search in athena that i
showed here today
it also has further documentation on
athena it has definitions for all of the
tables and fields so if there's a table
or field that you're not sure what it is
it's defined there and you can take a
look at that there's also information on
like the attacks on the
analysis tool and that kind of stuff if
you want to look at that
i've got a link here to amazon's at the
end of documentation on
saving your query results it's a little
more complete than what i was able to
show today because they've got a few
ways of doing that
and finally here's our getting started
playlist for sra on the cloud and
youtube
and that's got that video i mentioned
about how to set up an ec2 instance
and get started with the toolkit really
quickly as well as a few other things
that might be useful if you're new to
this
and then finally we've got just the ncbi
general help email address
and the sra help email address so if
you're trying to work on this and you're
having trouble querying the tables
you can write to sra and we'll be happy
to give you some assistance with that
and with that i'll say thank you very
much for your attention and i'll be
happy to take any questions that you
might have
thank you john there are some questions
go for it okay so the first question
although it's not completely clear
what this person is asking but basically
i think they want to know is the gis
aid uh accessions are those available or
are they mapped over to
some of the data that's in uh in the sra
in the cloud
you i am not sure about that i mean so
here in athena you mean the person who
asked that question if they can clarify
exactly what they want to know that i i
mean i think part of the question is
whether we have all that data
at all which is the gs aid is that
flu resources that collecting the um the
source cov2
uh data but yeah it's it's not avail
it's not available
in the athena tables currently um it
may be available locally at ncbi i'm not
100 sure about that
but we can get we can certainly get an
answer for that
question yeah another question for
nanopore sequencing reads is the raw
instrument output data available
yes so the raw output of data is
available for nanopore sequencing reads
that is distinct from like the sra
aligned reads i was showing here today
but we do provide the raw it's
assuming it was submitted with the raw
reads sometimes people submit nanopore
as
fast q or something in those cases we
don't have it but if we
if the raw and then import data is
submitted it should be available
from the cloud okay thank you and this
question is
good because it falls onto something you
just said about the
youtube channel so uh somebody was
asking
was there an equivalent webinar for
using bigquery and
gcp and the answer is yes there was that
and that webinar is available in the
youtube channel
the only difference i think is that that
doesn't talk about the the
read-a-line objects that you were
talking about today
that's right that that just covers total
sra metadata that's all that was
available then
so it doesn't cover like the read-align
objects or
the the metadata about those like the
blast results and the contact
information
but they're also are they also available
on gcp
they are okay okay and this is a
question that i am often confused about
and
um and it's about egress charges
so the question is for the sra public
data sets on aws or gcp
are there data egress charges if you
want to download your sra query results
for offline analysis
so for the data that's in the open data
registry
so that's the code related stuff that i
just talked about
which includes the new aligned reads
there is no egress charge for that
that's provided free of charge however
for
most but i guess not all of other sra
data that's
on the cloud there is an egress charge
usually so if you just want some other
run
that's that's in the cloud and you want
to download it from the cloud to local
storage for some reason
that would have an egress charge okay
thanks jonathan
another question is are you aware of any
client software that offers a higher
level of abstraction
uh in other words i think they're
looking for something that's um
that we'll look at at either aws or
athena
or gcp in a platform independent
manner does that make sense so you mean
to query this
data using some other yeah so that it
doesn't so that it wouldn't be dependent
on you know so for
for aws you have athena and for gcp you
have you know the bigquery
stuff is there something that sort of
works across the platforms i think
that's the question
for for querying i mean probably i'm not
aware of one
offhand i guess i mean so i will say so
for instance
the data we have stored in s3 i mean
it's formatted it's in part k format
it's designed to be efficiently queried
by athena we also offered in in json if
that's something you want so i mean
i'm sure there is a way that you could
query that independently if you wanted
to
but it's not particularly designed for
that
it's the the stuff in fdna has actually
been
tweaked to be efficient and um quickly
searched in athena okay and this
question and i'm not sure
i don't i don't understand what this is
so we can see if it's relevant to
today's webinar or not
um so it's the question is it's not
related to athena i just wanted to ask
you do you know which database the
p-a-n-v
scores can be found i don't know what
p-a-n-v scores are do you
i don't think i do know what that is
okay
well that's all the questions that we
have that are directly related to the
webinar today so
thanks everybody i'm going to go ahead
and end the webinar for everybody
thanks for coming
you